حمل قضائي كبير يحاصر الرئيس الامريكي
السابق واختبارات كثيره على طريق الوصول
الى البيت الابيض
ترامب سيمثل امام محكمه اتحاديه في ميامي
الساعه الثالثه ظهر الثلاثاء المقبل ومن
المتوقع ان يسلم نفسه للسلطات مسبقا وفي
تفاصيل يوم المحاكمه من غير المرجح ان
يلتقط صوره جنائيه للترامب لان هذه الصوره
تهدف بشكل عام الى المساعده في التعرف على
شخص ما وترامب هو من اكثر الشخصيات
المعروفه عالميا وفي حال تم التقاط صوره
جنائيه له فلا يمكن رؤيتها الا اذا تم
تسريبها استنادا الى سياسه عدم نشر الصور
اخذوا بصمات ترامب مره اخرى في فلوريدا
امر شبه حتمي لانها تعتبر ممارسه قياسيه
للتعامل مع المتهمين الجنائيين
الفيدراليين فيما لا يزال من غير الواضح
اذا كان سيتم اخذ عينات الحمض النووي ام
لا
لم يكن مقيد اليدين عندما القي القبض عليه
في نيويورك فليس من المحتمل ان يتم تقييد
يديه الاسبوع المقبل لذلك سيمثل ترامب
امام قاضن للاستماع الى التهم الموجهه
اليه وتقديم افاده اوليه بذنبه او براءته
ليحدد بعدها القاضي ما سيحدث حتى محاكمه
المدعى عليه
القواعد الصارمه بشان الاجهزه الالكترونيه
والتسجيلات والبث في المحاكم الفيدراليه
تمنع مشاهده محاكمه ترامب في حين سيكون
ايضا من الصعب الحصول على اي صوره له وهو
يمثل امام المحكمه اياد حمود العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات